in the lobby a financial piece Plaza is
Ty and Nikki hey guys how are you hey
are you
welcome welcome where are you guys from
right outside of Atlanta Oh phone rings
Georgia well cool well thanks for coming
to Nashville today and joining us as we
head into the Thanksgiving weekend I'm
guessing you're here to do a debt-free
scream without a dare
I love it and how much have you guys
paid off just over a hundred and forty
seven thousand dollars awesome how long
did that take you take us about three
years six months and 14 days give or
take everything I like it and what was
your household income during that three
years of six months and 14 days we began
about a hundred and forty and moved up
from there about one hundred and
sixty-eight excellent what do you guys
do for a living I am a black belt Six
Sigma process improvement guy for Yancy
brothers there in the state of Georgia
yeah my wife is a I work for Big
Brothers Big Sisters a non-profit I'm
the IT manager and the facility director
there oh wow two great careers excellent
very well done
absolutely incredible so what happened
three years ago three years six months
and 14 days ago that caused you to want
to get out of debt it was a I did my
taxes and saw the bottom line that that
uh based on those numbers what we made
and I had very very little to show for
it as a matter of fact we had nothing to
show for it a lot of a lot of debt a lot
of money went in and a lot of money went
out morning in the morning that came in
and it was pretty disappointing and
thought to myself and my grandmother
knew but I made and had nothing to show
for it
she was slapped me a few times so uh
that was that was deal the straw that
broke the camel's back really it was a
number of the things that kind of
influenced it a few services at our
church we're all friends were taken up
and we couldn't participate the help and
have family members or friends that are
connected to us that needed help and
weren't in a position to help and that
was very frustrating for us and then
looking at my kids
daven and then wanting to do some things
and wasn't able to do it
a great education great job but nothing
is known for it just felt felt helpless
lot of weight man sleepless nights and a
lot of stress on us so what kind of debt
was the hundred and forty seven thousand
you name it we had stupid we got that
t-shirt if you will we had a student
loans car debt credit cards family debt
this and that I mean it was every kind
of consumer debt you can think of Dave I
think the stupidest thing we've ever
done was purchased two BMWs brand-new
off the lot at the same time uh and so
you talk about still I think we lived
before we had kids we said why have kids
if you can have BMW so just really crazy
buddy wisdom yeah maturity love it I
love it so what do you tell people the
key is because your process guy if
anybody is I mean black belt Six Sigma
you know how to look at what has
happened here and unpack it it's how
you're trained if and so what has
happened in the three years six months
and 14 days what do you tell people the
keys are the key principles that drove
this process for you guys a plan and
accountability to things that we felt
absolutely necessary in order to do
anything to accomplish anything you got
to have a plan the Bible says write the
vision and make it plain and and and I
believe that's what we did over the last
three years we wrote a vision we sat
down and we said this is where we want
to be in this what we want to do we live
by a budget that's our plan before the
money comes in we write it down I love
it and we tell our money where to go
instead of our money telling us where to
go and then on top of that the
accountability my wife and I are great
team but we have others around us that
just encourages at our church I got your
book from from a friend of mine at my
church in fact I'm gonna taking my new
one about I still have it
pastor Randy and Tracy they're great
friends of accountability there that
held our hand through this process and
really encouraged us so that
accountability both within the marriage
as well as out that supported us was
very
important Nikki what was the hardest
thing you guys did in the last three
years to make this happen well for me it
was it was interesting to figure out how
to get creative so with the emergency
fund and with the way he would budget
because he had extreme I call him micro
focus know around the budget you would
mean every day he's got his eye on where
the pennies are not the big dollars but
every penny so he would say okay it's a
her birthday's coming up you have $100
beep it out so I have to get down and
figure out what I could do with $100 for
a particular birthday or Christmas is
coming you have this amount of money and
so it at first it was challenging to
maneuver under those types of
restrictions and constraints but now
it's it's our way of life not when you
all were putting the budget together you
had a say in that but that he came back
and said hey this is the budget we
agreed to and this is what it means for
you and wasn't like he was just telling
you no absolutely we're we're a team and
I would say okay I need some shoes and
he would say okay let's talk about it
okay this is what the shoe budget is
going to be you can have the money on
this day and I would take the money and
make miracles happen you get real
creative when you have to read yes you
can I love it well congratulations what
was the one debt that when you paid it
off you said I hate you people I'm never
going back in debt for me it was the
student loan because that was a debt
that I carried into the marriage and it
wasn't even a lot of it wasn't a large
amount of money but I just think that I
was of the mindset that you're always
going to have the student loan I'm
always going to have the student loan I
might even die with this loan so when
the loan that loan was paid off it was
just knows a break through a big weight
off of me yeah you could feel the things
snap in the spirit oh yeah that's cool
yeah the chains are coming off yes I
love it that is so fun now what are your
kids names this is Pallas it was eight
sigh this is Paris who's 12 alright
she's kind of here that's it god I love
it so they know what's going on or if
you guys just kind of done it and they
watched no they've been very involved in
Paris has even offered up her allowance
here and there to try to help to
expedite the plan but we told her to
keep her money
we'll keep going and keep attacking and
believe it or not Dave we've been
talking about coming on this show for
about three years Wow so we made a plan
to come here it's a big day it's a very
big day and we came just for you
you don't have any family here we're not
here for Thanksgiving yeah okay Wow well
that's absolutely incredible I'm honored
to be part of the goal and part of the
victory as well that you guys got to
come up here so these kids they get it
and more importantly have you realized
yet that you not only got out of debt
but you probably have changed your whole
family tree that is that it was my
motivation they one of the things I
think you know we look back on it when
we first started and thought why didn't
I know this both great education and
just felt like I was ill-equipped either
in personal life marriage
so that's that's a big thing for us we
actually teach a marriage class and and
lead couples through love and respect no
you're very familiar where so the
address good stuff and and so so for us
it's about not just our family tree for
others as well yeah I've got a number of
people that are watching today
and just want this to encourage them
that they can do it it's not about us
God has no respective person man he is
he's able to do for me exactly what what
he's able to do for me he can do for you
so you know anything we can do to
influence and help others that's what
this has really been about and so we're
just excited man thank you so much for
your gift you're such a gift man and
just wanted I've been waiting and
praying for the day I could come and
tell you I love thank you we're honored
to have you guys today all right gather
the folks around Nicky and Ty and gang
from Atlanta Georgia a hundred and forty
seven thousand dollars paid off in three
years six months and 14 days count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one
crowd and Martha's place goes wild
congratulations you guys very well done
that is seriously fun yeah and you guys
are listening
you're next yeah you talking to you this
is the Dave Ramsey show